welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as marvel assembles its new
lineup of hunks
some conflicting reports have suggested
shia labeouf
is being targeted to play a major role
in an upcoming mcu title
a recent report suggested he's being
considered as mutant bobby drake
iceman a report i was surprised to see
since you know i figured they'd go a bit
younger for that role
maybe give a chance to a younger lesser
known actor who might fit the part
better like we ain't talking even
steven's holes
transformers shia this is tatted up see
you dancing tax collecting
indoors jaya and i have been more
interested in the reports of him being
considered for
mark spector moon knight a name we keep
seeing over and over
and like ninety percent of you are like
and marvel studios is like he's legion
batman you're gonna love him trust us
la buff is among the leading dudes in
consideration for the role along with
reportedly adam driver
daniel radcliffe was rumored earlier
this year but we can confirm he will not
be
moon knight i am going to explain who
moon knight
is the possible sightings we've had of
him in the mcu so far
all the latest updates we now know about
his disney plus series
and why moon knight is going to be so
important to other future marvel titles
like dr strange ii
blade and marvel's secret plans for
characters like punisher like ghost
rider
spoiler warning in case i'm right
alright moon knight is mark spector son
of a rabbi who trains as a boxer and
becomes a cia agent
a u.s marine and later comic recons a
mercenary whose body gets possessed by
the egyptian moon deity
konshu endowing him with supernatural
strength reflexes agility
based on the fullness of the moon in its
lunar cycle spectre returns to america
imposes
as the wealthy elite identity stephen
grant to hide from his mercenary past
but then he realizes he needs another
identity to roam the streets as a crime
fighter so he takes on the
additional identity as taxi driver jake
lockley really the best known
explorations of the character
and the reason i'm pretty sure marvel
prioritized the title for live-action
adaptation
is the focus on mark spector's egyptian
origin story as
a possible symptom of dissociative
identity disorder which would also
explain his ease to take on identities
like steve grant and jake lockley in
addition to his mark specter in moon
knight identities
mark struggles to confirm for himself
which of his experiences were real
and whether his possession by khan shu
was a delusion within his own mind it's
a very
interesting angle on the character that
marvel hasn't really explored in other
titles now over the years
many have diminished moon knight as
marvel's batman bruce wayne but
obviously there's a lot more to this
character he's closer in my eyes to
legion
the mutant adapted in the amazing fx
series that framed his mutant abilities
as a psychological disorder now the mcu
so far hasn't really mentioned mark
specter
aside from some brief easter eggs that
some have argued our moon knight
references
like in captain america the winter
soldier sit well listed a man
in cairo as a hydra target the tv anchor
in cairo the under secretary defends a
high school valedictorian in iowa city
but mark spector wasn't a tv anchor most
likely this was more likely referring to
the egyptian media during the arab
spring
who were often targeted and threatened
some have also said that you could see
moon knight's ankh among the relics and
dr strange's sanctum sanctorum
but i've never been able to find it and
i can find everything
but there have been some rumored leaks
about plot details that could tell us
about how moon knight will connect to
the rest of the mcu
i know this is a lot to process so let's
shift gears to something smaller more
digestible more compact
like the most discreet front pocket
while at the ridge thanks to the ridge
for sponsoring this episode
the ridge helps you carry what you need
every day from their flagship ridge
wallet to
their portable charging commuter
backpack they want to make the most out
of what you're bringing with you the
ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
carbon fiber it has a clean stylish look
it's chainsaw proof so when all those
tiki hating
jerks come at you with chainsaws their
attacks will be
not very effective this is their
aluminum tiki wallet they do have other
colors like matte cobalt blue or
forged carbon fiber all of them they're
light they're strong they're
ready to party but only with the minimal
amount of cash that you brought with you
because you don't need to bring
everything they make it easy to buy with
free shipping and free returns and a
lifetime guarantee it's got
thirty thousand five star reviews so you
know they're doing something right they
also have great backpacks and travel
bags with rfid blocking pockets and
optional device charging batteries
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com rockstars
and use the code new rockstars
find the link in the video's description
okay the latest reports about moon
knight again unconfirmed
is that the moon knight series will put
mark spector in the midst of a psychic
tug of war between warring controlling
entities the egyptian moon god konchu
and another moon knight villain
stained glass scarlet an ex-nun turned
vigilante
this report suggested that the series
will have a narrative structure
similar to westworld or pulp fiction
which to me suggests a non-linear
timeline that jumps around to different
points in the chronology again
like legion reflecting the point of view
of a character in an unstable
psychological condition who cannot trust
his perception
and finally this report suggests that
joining the series
will be vampires and stake
a sister organization to shield an
acronym for special threat assessment
for known extra normalities
as its wordplay name suggests it
oversees paranormal
supernatural horror threats in the
marvel world like vampires zombies
werewolves not to be confused with sword
sentient world observation response
department the shield offshoot that
focuses on interplanetary defenses and
extraterrestrial threats
which is confirmed to be joining the mcu
as soon as one division
and might be that squirrel space station
nick fury was looking for his shoes on
in the far from home post credit scene
steak appearing in moon knight would
increase likelihood of the expected
tie-in
with marvel's blade reboot and the
possible formation of the team
called the midnight suns which would
include
blade moon knight joined with morbius
living vampire
you know with sony making it super
confusing which cinematic universe he's
part of as well as
frank castle punisher with increasing
calls from fans to bring in
jon bernthal's punisher from the netflix
side of the universe also joining that
lineup could be
ghostwriter who did appear in a past
season of agents of shield
and has similar support from fans to
bring that character to bigger screens
though recently agents of shield
confirmed that it did create a new
timeline separate from the mcu
and it's always been a debate how much
that series is true mcu cannon
don't act many aos heads i know i saw
that jarvis cameo in game 2 but that's
not the same as saying kevin feige gives
any shits about bits and simmons i'm
sorry
the midnight sons would be yet another
team of heroes in the marvel world in
these upcoming story lines
so who's gonna be the new avengers well
here's how i think marvel could organize
all of it
as i have stated multiple times before
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness appears to be the pivotal nexus
of this next
phase being set up as a kind of world
colliding crossover event
that could condense multiple universes
in multiple genres
all within a broader mcu with doctor
strange as the key to
it all think about it strange had a
front row seat to the avengers
shortcomings in the conflict with thanos
he saw exactly what happens when one
mashup of competing egos chaotically
scrambles to fight
all kinds of battles at once you gotta
diversify you gotta scale
out and you know what's better than one
superhero team a
billion superhero teams well we'll work
our way up to that but for now we'll
start with eight
consider the sorcerer's supreme as a
kind of league
commissioner overseeing and regulating a
roster of marvel teams and organizations
among them the new avengers to handle
avengers level calamities
the midnight suns to handle supernatural
threats
the thunderbolts to handle dangerous
special ops and suicide missions that
you don't want to put the frontmen on
the defenders to protect urban streets
the neighborhoods
the x-men to reign in growing mutant
threats like the brotherhood of mutants
fantastic four to handle threats from
other dimensions
the rockford peaches and the illuminati
as an inner circle of brainiacs to
govern it all and laugh at the rick and
morty jokes the rest of us are too dumb
to get
hopefully as we start to get more
information about moon knight and what
character shia labeouf is playing next
year
it will be within the framework of a
vast league of marvel teams
comment down below with your thoughts on
this theory and which character you want
shia labeouf to play and join the nerdy
discussion on our official discord
server by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars follow me on
instagram at eavos
follow new rockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
do it
[Music]